Here I've built a fake internet
It's a little smaller than the real internet, but it'll be a good example
for showing how we want to modify the crawler to solve the max pages problem.
The problem asks us to stop the crawler
from crawling the internet after we've reached a certain number of pages.
If this were the real internet, there'd be a lot more links. We'd have links going basically practically forever.
There are billions of pages on the internet, and if we took
the code that we had at the end of this unit,
then the crawler would go on for a very, very long time.
I leave it up to you to estimate how long it would take,
but longer than this course has time available.
What we want to do for all practical reasons
is have the crawler stop after reaching a certain number of pages.
That's pretty easy to do if we just count the number of pages
that we've seen as we go through our sample internet and simply check it
against the max pages passed into the function.
If we say max pages is equal to 3, what our crawler is going to do is start with A.
>From A, we're going to crawl A, then get B and C.
Then we're going to crawl C, and get D and E,
but we now have crawl 3 pages, so we want to stop the process.
Let's look at the code that we had at the end of the unit and modify it to do exactly this.
Here we have the crawl web function.
We take in a parameter--max pages--
and we want to stop crawling once we've hit that number of pages crawled.
An easy way to check is to simply look at the length of the crawled list,
and we get that but using the len operator.
We don't only want to crawl a page if it hasn't been crawled,
but we also only want to crawl it if the length of the crawled list is less than max_pages.